this is the beginning of patrick jones
from this time on his life is going to
be a constant conflict
reality necessity and duty opposing
desires dreams and distractions
these conflicts exist in every human
being
and we must learn how to deal with them
ten years later he is still immature in
thought and action
thinking acting pat jones who can raise
more health than any kid on the block
he has plenty of fun some of it not
exactly in accord with adult ideas of
peace and quiet
but all in the routine pattern of
boyhood
it makes him feel a little important to
heckle his father
not in any spirit of meanness but
because the old man represents authority
and discipline
yes over the years dad has learned that
firecracker shooting must be restricted
at times
and this is going to hurt dad more than
it does pat
as pat grows older he finds it pleasant
to have people make a fuss over him
like the time when he won first prize in
an interscholastic contest
or when he hurt his knee in the
championship football game
and so covered himself with glory that
everybody made over and waited on him
he was the four-star local hero and he
loved it
as who wouldn't inside himself
unconsciously
pat will always carry with him this
memory
and dad was proud as a peacock he showed
the newspaper clippings until they were
worn out
this is home and it's great friendly and
protective
home means mom's deep dish apple pie so
good dad always had three pieces
and it's sitting around listening to the
radio playing a little gin rummy with
the old man
it's where he can call up margie
whenever he likes ask her to the movies
or to a dance
or just down to the drugstore for a soda
or if he feels like being alone he can
go up to his own room
there's something mighty comforting
about your own room
and he's a man on his own too paying his
own way
earning his own living patrick jones
junior foreman holding down a job with a
paycheck every saturday
and a good one for a guy of his age
patrick r
jones patrick r jones i see they're
closing you out
closing me out i quit bill goss hell not
sorry you're leaving jones i'm getting a
better job
and he could quit his job whenever he
liked for whatever reason he liked
overnight his home life is left behind
and he's one of millions of men
each one a seaman jones that means that
he isn't necessarily our seaman jones
this seaman jones may have graduated
from one of the ritziest colleges in new
england
or he could be semen rabinowitz who
never made it beyond the sixth grade of
a public school
this one could have been one of the
seven swenson kids from a farm
or o'brien who never knew his folks and
was raised in an orphanage
but whoever a man is you can tell a lot
about him
by what's in his heart seaman jones
might be a little along in years have a
wife and kids
then again he could be just a kid
himself and still looking him over if
you know what i mean
or he could be the boy who's been going
steady with the girl who's always been
his
and always will be
so let's take a look at the inside story
of this seaman jones
who's gone from this to this
from mom's deep dish apple pie to a mess
line
from his own room to this
noise confusion
no privacy
the change is a big one and he's having
a hard time adjusting himself to this
new life
seaman jones is homesick unhappy and
disturbed
lots of things seem to be combining to
worry him
he feels that he's being unfairly
neglected by his family and his girl
he's had no mail for four days now and
it seems as though he's the only one who
misses
he's having trouble concentrating on his
classwork
doesn't seem able to follow and he's the
boy who used to win the silver cups in
high school
all in all this is no picnic says seaman
jones
he finds himself panicky and lost in a
crowd of countless men
where everybody looks alike and is
treated alike
no glory here like the time he was a
football hero
he's really worried about himself so
much so that one night
my liberty this weekend are we going out
tomorrow
what if i get my stripes exam coming up
tomorrow
here i've got the jitters
exams exams
maybe i'm going nuts maybe you'll drive
me crazy
then on top of all his other problems
seaman jones
who'd always been a gay friendly guy who
got along with other people
found himself unable to enter into the
general easy companionship
of the men with whom he was living and
working
instead of joining in he resented the
sometimes loud rowdy
fun in the barracks nobody seemed to
care how he felt
well if all that isn't enough to trouble
one guy
all of a sudden the knee he twisted in
that grand and glorious football game
went back on him it really hurt plenty
but at least he can have that taken care
of
and a mighty good doctor looks it over
with the greatest care
but the doctor can't find anything
organically wrong with the knee
now the most startling thing about this
upset is that seaman jones isn't gold
breaking
his knee really hurts and it's not
imagination either
he feels the pain that's how he knows
it's there
that's important and it's frightening
too because on top of troubles with
studies
nightmares and loneliness what can be
wrong
he'd better do something about it he
does the most sensible thing he can
possibly do
goes to the mental health department and
sees the psychiatrist
for naturally an emotional upset must be
treated differently from an organic
illness
jones tells his story the doctor is
neither surprised or alarmed
for this isn't a news story to him
amazing as it is to jones
and he knows the answer an answer the
jones can understand because there
aren't a lot of strange highfalutin
terms
today we're making a scientific study of
the mind
and we're finding some very encouraging
things
now this nervous breakdown that you're
afraid of for instance
well the truth is nobody has a nervous
breakdown
ever they don't nerves
our physical nerves don't break
we do get into mental and emotional
moods that make us pretty unhappy
the results of all the difficulties and
conflicts that beset us
that we've reacted to that we've had
difficulty in adjusting to
now your symptoms suggest that you're in
such a mood
a mood of anxiousness even your physical
symptoms like the aching knee you told
me about
can have an emotional cause i'll explain
that in a moment
anxiousness is quite a common mood it
makes a person focus his attention
much more closely on himself perhaps
he notices his heart beating or his
muscles tensing
yes people often think in this mood of
anxiousness that it's leading to a
mental illness actually
it almost never does perhaps i can help
you if i give you an idea of how your
mind works
you see jones emotions actually can
cause real
physical pain the conscious mind is a
pleasant sunny place
where normal thoughts have free reign
the unconscious mind is dark and
mysterious and harbor such thoughts as
i'm lonesome nobody pays any attention
to me
i wish i were dead i must be losing my
mind
these thoughts are constantly trying to
get into the conscious mind
to get past the sensor who polices the
band
it's his job to keep them out
here's a little thought that keeps
popping up
i wished i was dead huh
what did you say i said i wished i was
dead
uh uh i must be stupid i just can't see
things clearly
outside bums yo what do you think about
you'll get the light for me for
reservations
someone's always picking on me
nobody pays any attention to me they're
blind to real talent
watch this
holy cats i must be losing mine
censored out of the conscious mind these
self-pitying thoughts
tumble into the lap of old unconscious
mind
the dormant parent of all your emotions
and arouse him with their clamor
they goad him to find another way for
them to assert themselves on your
conscious mind
so this brute who never forgets anything
that ever happened to you
remembers a certain incident
which got you a nice lot of sympathetic
attention in the past
an incident which your conscious mind
may have completely forgotten
but your unconscious remembers and now
he knows just what to do
i've got it boys into the car with you
come on fellas let's go
why didn't we think of this before
that's why your knee hurt even though
there's nothing physically wrong with it
well i'm sure glad to hear that a lot of
boys feel about the way you do
there was another seaman in here a few
days ago named scott
a big strapping lad who during his
civilian days never had
anything wrong with him he won golden
glove
tournaments and was a very pretty
fighter indeed
then he landed in the coast guard and
found himself no more important than any
other seaman
he found himself being ordered around by
a petty officer
half his size being told what to do and
how to do it
having his hat straightened for him and
even having the lint dusted off his
clothes
he a champion in his own right
and even in the classroom he found
himself thrown for a loss by simple
navigation
he just couldn't turn out an adequate
notebook
so one day he turned up at sick bay with
a bad stomach ache
the physical exam x-ray and laboratory
studies
proved there was nothing physically
wrong so he was sent to the psychiatrist
what went on in his mind was something
like this he had a lot of self-pitying
thoughts running around in his mind for
all his toughness
and of course he wouldn't let his
conscious mind think
the sensor chases them into his
unconscious mind
and old man unconscious decides
that what seaman scott needs is a darn
good foolproof excuse for not doing so
well right now
he takes care of that in his own way
hey fellas come on
you're always picking on me now it's my
turn to do the picking
everybody has emotional disturbances and
nobody is really strong enough to
control his emotions absolutely
i have some notes here that i'll give
you
look them over they may clear up some of
the things that have been bothering you
thank you sir
so seaman jones did study the notes and
found them even more helpful than he
hoped
they were interesting understandable and
they made sense
get the professor would you some notes
the doctor gave me
how to go nuts in three easy lessons or
something hey you ought to give it to
some of my petty officers
i got a guy over me that's a real
frankenstein
no it worries me oh yeah it says right
here
maybe you're blaming your petty officer
because you've got a sneaking feeling
that you can't keep up with the rest of
the fellows
you mean it's me that's nuts everybody
does funny things
listen to this inside of us there is
always a battle going on between what we
want to do
and what we've got to do yeah that's the
way i feel all right
somehow whenever i get a dirty job to do
no matter what kind
maybe like swabbing down the deck i
can't seem to think straight
all of a sudden i ain't seeming kelly no
more i'm somebody else
i look at all that deck that's gotta be
suave then oh
and his mind is a million miles away as
he dreams himself into an
out-of-the-world hero
this time as a spy in hirohito's palace
a sort of sea going dick tracy hey kelly
of course there has to be a reward for a
daring deed like that
and it's a real double-barreled
homecoming fork yep
admiral kelly right down fifth avenue
and this is so real he can hear the
crowd yelling his name kelly
kelly kelly get to work
yeah sure
sure sure that's why i can't stand that
petty officer
well is it because he's a bad egg or
just because he had to pull you back to
reality
no don't get me no argument son well all
right maybe it was
come on give out with more of our
problems mr anthony well
maybe some of you guys don't like these
man-to-man combat drills i always did
hate them
well look you don't have to be no saw
bones to figure that one out
you got an inferior inferiority dingus
yeah it's like what they call an
inferiority complication
it says here when you have a feeling of
inadequacy
when you feel you can't keep up with the
competition you may begin to blame the
task you're having trouble with
instead of realizing it is your own
weakness that is troubling you well
does it tell me how i can get cured well
sure you've got to know something about
it
now everyone has inferiority it's not
that that's bad
theory already helps us a lot of times
because we try to improve ourselves
now if we do something that turns out
good that helps us
but there's always inferiority in all
people yeah but that's just horse sense
the doc says mental health is just
applying common sense to your emotional
problems
sure only books got to put it in fancy
words so the guy who wrote it can get
three bucks a copy for it
hey get this it is hard to recognize
jealousy in oneself
for example most of us secretly wish we
could be all american athletes
because we can't we like to say athletes
are dumbbells
all brawn and no brains and that my
fellow scientists is what is known as
the saw grapes complex that's maybe why
we say most beautiful girls are dumb
you think that's bad
no but if we know what it is we can use
it to help us to get ahead see
where did you get that fortune telling
bunch of notes anyway the doc gave it to
me
a couple of weeks ago i started to get
well i thought my nerves would snap but
it seems they can't snap
your nervous system is just like
anything else it gets
tired and upset but a good night's sleep
or
a little play and relaxation it's okay
again nerves don't break
it's our feelings that get the best of
us say no kidding
you know what i'm afraid of what what no
i'm afraid of being a coward gee
me too no sometimes i can't think of
anything else
i know you think i'm a doe for something
but sometimes i go in the chapel
and i sit there and i start sweating and
i say
keep me from being a coward oh god
what am i going to do if i get into
action somewhere
and i get so scared i turn traitor
that's a natural terrible fear the fear
of doing this
running away a fear we all have
yet it's a normal fear for it's deep
rooted in every animal
we call it the instinct of
self-preservation
animals react to it instinctively in
order to protect themselves
so we know that we may be afraid but
fear
and cowardice are not the same in fact
fear is an emotion which has always
protected us
for example here's an american submarine
cruising quietly
suddenly an enemy bomb crashes
it doesn't explode but it's live and it
can any second
and it's jammed in an almost
inaccessible place below
only this skinny boy can get at it
he must remove the detonator even though
he doesn't know how
he scared blue he can be guided only by
instructions from a loudspeaker
but here's a great thing about fear
sometimes
in this case for instance it can
actually help
for it causes an instantaneous change to
occur in our bodies
so that every muscle and organ goes into
high gear
to help us through the emergency as it's
helping the semen
while he's literally got the sub and the
lives of the crew in his hands
stimulated by fear the heart pumps
faster to carry more blood through the
arteries
the glands step up their secretions of
vitalizing fluids into the system
and he's doing what he has to do as
frightened as you will ever be
fear is acting helpfully to heighten all
responses
waste materials which might slow us down
are quickly thrown off
and there comes an amazing intensity of
concentration to carry us through
emergencies
you can see the terror in this man's
face but by stepping up his physical
reactions
to help him through the most dangerous
crisis of his life
fear has become his a lie instead of his
enemy
aided by fear he's done it
now seaman jones and the rest of his
mates who are troubled
understand more fully some of the
sources and causes of their worries
and as a result jones is no longer
lonely and out of things
he's one of the guys he's learned what
his mistakes were
and corrected some of them he's adjusted
to his new environment
and he's doing all right the same is
true of seaman scott
he's all straightened out now and is
doing a swell job
he even thinks of those bugaboo petty
officers as good guys now
this one's a swell ping-pong player too
scott has finally found the right
outlets for his energy and ambition
and kelly the dreamer he's not dreaming
now
he's having a good time and he's
studying hard
for he's learned that it's only through
our own efforts that we achieve real
satisfaction
yes all people must learn to live and
work in harmony
must assume new responsibilities and
take pride in their duties
that's what is now reflected in these
men's faces as they get
combat orders anderson looks confident
kelly's alert and ready scott is a cool
steady warrior
and seaman jones is going after new
recognition
so then we see how troubles fade as we
learn even a little about our minds
and thereby protect ourselves against
some of the unconscious trends to which
we are subject
sound mental health is our nation's
greatest asset
and this we must maintain with it let us
have pride
pride in our core and in our service
we must have faith and hope in our cause
our way of life and for a better world
tomorrow